je suis verdict maurin adjointe à
l'embellissement et à la promotion de la
nature à plaisir nous avons la fête de
la nature qui se déroule ce week-end sur
notre ville ce parc aujourd'hui qui est
magnifique qui dispose aussi d'un plan
d'eau accueillera de nombreuses
manifestations durant cette fête de la
nature
[Musique]
le plan d'eau et offre de nombreuses
possibilités
nous avons un autre plan d'eau bois de
la crâne qui lui aussi accueillera une
manifestation pour la découverte de la
des peuples de l'eau nous avons choisi
en fait deux thèmes cette année un thème
de la nature nourricière et le thème de
la faune nocturne donc d'autant fort
pour ce pur celui qu'elle notamment la
plantation d'un verger dans le quartier
de l'aqueduc qui est un quartier très
urbanisées et nous accueillons une
association l'association les petits qui
piquent qui préserve et qui tend à
sensibiliser la préservation des
hérissons tous les lieux qui sont
aujourd'hui à plaisir et qui met en
valeur cette cette nature seront mis à
l'honneur donc le parc du château avec
des découvertes grâce à un naturaliste
photographes amateurs
nous avons bien sûr aussi la découverte
des abeilles nous avons un apiculteur
sûr plaisir qui viendra animer des
ateliers
[Applaudissements]
on pense souvent connaître la nature et
finalement il ya beaucoup d'aspects
qu'on découvre lorsqu'on s'y intéressent
vraiment les ateliers découverte
aujourd'hui permettent cette meilleure
connaissance donc j'invite tous les
plaisirs oies et les personnes aux
alentours à se référer au programme qui
est sur le site de la ville et à venir
découvrir dans le détail cette nature